in the last video we tried to come up
with a somewhat rigorous definition of
what a limit is where we say when you
say that the limit of f of X as X
approaches C is equal to L you're really
saying and this is the somewhat rigorous
definition that you can get f of X as
close as you want to L by making X
sufficiently close to C so let's see if
we can put a little bit meat on it so
instead of saying as close as you want
let's call that some positive number
epsilon so I'm just going to use the
Greek letter epsilon right over there
so it really turns into a game so you
you tell me how close you want so this
is the game you tell me how close you
want f of X to be to L and you do this
by giving me a positive number that we
call epsilon which is really how close
you want it you want f of X to be to L
so you give a positive positive number
epsilon and epsilon is how close do you
want to be how close so for example if
epsilon is 0.01 that says that you want
f of X to be within 0.01 of Epsilon and
so what I then do is I say well okay
you've given me that epsilon I'm going
to find you I will find you another
number find another positive number
another number which we'll call Delta
the lower case Delta the Greek letter
Delta such that so I'll say where if X
is within is within Delta of C then f of
X will be within epsilon of our limit so
let's see if these are really saying the
same thing in this yellow definition
right over here we said you can get f of
X as close as you want to L by making X
sufficiently close to see this second
definition which I kind of made is a
little bit more of a game is doing the
same thing someone is saying how close
they want f of X to be to L and the
burden is is then to find a delta where
as long as X is within Delta of C that f
of X will be within epsilon of the limit
so that is doing it it's saying look if
we were constraining X in such a way
that if X is in that range to see that f
of X will be as close as you want so
let's make this a little bit clearer by
diagramming right over here you show up
and you say well I want f of X to be
within epsilon of our limit so this
right over here this right over here
would this point right over here is our
limit plus epsilon and this right over
here might be our limit minus this right
over here is limit minus Epsilon and you
say okay sure I think I can do I can I
can get your f of X within within this
range of our limit and I can do that by
defining a range around C and it really
it could you know I could visually look
at this boundary but I could even go
narrow or that boundary I could I could
go I can go right over here says okay I
meet your challenge I will find another
number Delta so this right over here is
C plus Delta this right over here is C
minus right this down is C minus Delta
so I'll find you some Delta so that if
you take any X you take any X in the
range C minus Delta to C plus Delta and
maybe the function is not even defined
at C so we we think of ones that maybe
aren't C but are getting very close if
you find any X in that range F of those
X's are going to meet your are going to
be as close as you want to your limit
they're going to be within the range L
plus Epsilon or L minus Epsilon so
what's another way of saying this
another way of saying this is you give
me an epsilon then I will find you a
Delta so let me write this a little bit
more math notation so I'll write the
same exact statement a little bit more a
little bit more a little math you what's
the exact same thing so you give me you
give or let me write it this way given
given given and epsilon greater than
zero we can find so that's kind of the
first part of the game we can find a
delta greater than 0 such that such that
if X if X is within Delta of C so what's
another way of saying that X is X is
within Delta of C well one way you could
say well what's the distance between X
and C is going to be less than Delta
this statement is true for any X any X
that's within Delta of C the difference
between the two is going to be less than
Delta so that if you pick an X that is
in in this range between C minus Delta
and C plus Delta and that's these are
the X's that satisfy that right over
here then then and I'll do this in a new
color then the distance between your f
of X f of X and your limit and this is
just the distance between the f of X and
the limit it's going to be less than
Epsilon
so all this is saying is if if if the
limit truly does exist it truly is L is
if you give me any positive number
epsilon it could be a super super small
one we can find a delta so we can define
a range around C so that if we take any
X any x value that is within Delta of C
that's all this statement is saying that
the distance between X and C is less
than Delta so it's within Delta C so
that's these points right over here that
f of those X's that f of at the the
function evaluated at those X's is going
to be within the range that you are
specifying it's going to be within
epsilon of our limit the f of X the
difference between f of X and your limit
will be less than epsilon your f of X is
going to sit is going to sit someplace
over there so that's all the epsilon
Delta definition is telling us in the
next video we will prove that a limit
exists by using this definition of
limits